okay you guys asked for it so part two  of my parents bought a water slide and  the town didn't want them to put it up  but for those of you that didn't know my  parents bought a water slide about two  or three years ago from a water park and  not gonna lie it's a little bit of an  eyesore see that's the slide that's the  house and initially when we started  building the slide it was fine it's  about two or three years ago and we got  issued a permit and we started to build  it was cool  but then people started to complain  and they started to say we weren't  allowed to build the slide because we  weren't allowed to have a structure  that's bigger than the house and clearly  you can see or taller i should say but  you can see that's taller than the house  and my parents basically had to go to  this like hall type thing to like talk  about the slide i don't really know the  full story because i wasn't there okay  i'm running out of time but like for  part three to see what happens next